you know memory is a remarkable thing
and the way it can be manipulated for
good and for ill is quite remarkable
because of its inherent flexibility what
you see here is a cell from the
hippocampus which is the main organ of
memory in the human mind actually in all
organs Minds thankfully our nervous
system is designed to be flexible so
that it can learn about the world and
modify its understanding of the world
you see all the time we're learning we
have a little model of the world in our
brains which actually predicts what're
going to see so that when something is
different we notice it right away it's a
very efficient system of staying alert
to threats and so brain scientists these
days actually refer to the brain as a
prediction
machine but that also means that the
brain to be efficient has to throw away
a lot of information it judges to be
irrelevant and unimportant and thus I
say that for a good memory forgetting is
a feature it's not a bug in short memory
is the raw material of our ourselves as
individuals and as members of society it
comprises our identity in effect to
hijack history is tan amount to identity
theft and it is to my mind a political
crime whoever commits
[Music]
it